meanwhile there's some astonishing news
from the polling front okay on the
polling front democrats are in such
unbelievable trouble according to gallup
on average america's political
preferences in 2021 looked similar to
prior years with slightly more u.s
adults identifying as democrats or
leaning democratic than identified as
republicans or leaning republican about
46 democratic and 43 republican however
the general stability for the full year
average obscures a dramatic shift over
the course of 2021 from a nine
percentage point democratic advantage in
the first quarter of 2021 to a
five-point republican edge in the fourth
quarter 47
identified as republican or lean
republican compared to 42 percent who
identified as lean democrat
and that is extraordinarily rare the
nine point democratic advantage in the
first quarter and the five-point
republican edge in the fourth quarter
are among the largest gallop has
measured for either party in any quarter
since it began regularly measuring party
id and leaning in 1991.
the gop has held as much as a five-point
advantage in a total of only four
quarters since 1991.
the republicans last held a five-point
advantage in party identification and
leaning in early 1995 after winning
control of the house of representatives
for the first time since the 50s so
basically the last time there was a
giant enormous unprecedented republican
wave
that was 1994
and that is when republican numbers
looked like this one
the only other time the republicans had
a larger advantage is when george w bush
was at like 90 in the approval ratings
at the beginning of the gulf war
okay for democrats their lead in the
first quarter was the largest for the
party since the first fourth quarter of
2012 which is of course when barack
obama won re-election
shifting party preferences in 2021
according to gallup are likely tied to
changes in popularity of the two men who
served as president during the year
donald trump finished out his single
term in january after being defeated in
2020 with a 34 job approval rating
that's the lowest of his term
his popularity fell more than 10 points
from election day 2020 as the country's
coveted 19 infections and deaths reached
record highs as well as the january 6th
events
meanwhile joe biden had relatively high
ratings and then those absolutely
collapsed
and so what we saw in the fourth quarter
is this massive shift toward the
republicans
according to gallup the shifts in party
affiliation in each quarter of 2021 were
apparent in both the percentage
identifying with each party and the
percentage of independence leaning to
each party but with more changes among
leaners than identifiers between the
first and fourth quarters the percentage
of democratic identifiers decreased by
two points the percentage of democratic
leaning independence dropped by five
points
republican identification increased by
three points republican leaners
increased by four points
okay so that is a that is a massive
shift in favor of the republicans it is
extremely rare
and uh and democrats are in real and
serious trouble
not just that according to gallup
you can see what has happened within the
parties and this is the reason why
there's been the shift against the
democrats so if you look at americans
political ideology by year
across the country about 36 percent of
americans identify as conservative
another 37 percent of americans identify
as moderate that means that 73 of
americans are either conservative or
moderate
how many identify as liberal
so that is a not great number for the
folks on the left particularly because
all of those liberals identify only with
the democratic party
the democratic party used to be a lot
more politically diverse
but the simple fact of the matter is
that right now the democratic party has
moved in a wildly left direction if you
look at the democrats political ideology
according to gallup what it shows is
that in 1994 only 25 percent of
democrats identified as liberal
right about 20 same number identified as
conservative so it was about 25
conservative 25 liberal and about 50
moderate
today
only 12 percent of democrats identify as
conservative 37
identify as moderate 50 identify as
liberal so liberals remember only
constitute about 25 of the entire
american population but they are 50 of
the democratic party
moderates constitute only about 37
percent of the democratic party down
from 48 in 1994
and there are no conservatives left in
the democratic party 12 percent of
democrats identify as conservatives
meanwhile the numbers for independence
have remained essentially the same
in 1994 46 identified as moderate today
that's 48
31 identified as conservative today
that's 30
18 identified as liberal today that's 20
so in other words the democratic party
moved to the left
and now everybody else has moved to the
right
that's the story of american politics
the republican party identifies more
openly as conservative but the moderates
have been left behind by the democratic
party
which is a disaster for the democratic
and you can see that these demographics
are really bad for the democratic party
if you look at americans political
ideology by subgroup in 2021
what you see
is that only people 18 to 29
predominantly identify as liberal
okay the the vast majority of people
in the united states first of all the
vast majority of people or plurality of
people 18 to 29 identify as moderate but
among people who identify as liberal the
plurality are young 18 to 29.
among people who identify as
conservative
the plurality are older
and moderates are sort of evenly spread
across the board well here's the problem
this is an older country gang
so the demographics actually do not run
in favor of the democratic party at this
point
and here is what's particularly
hilarious okay here is how racial groups
identify you ready so this is totally
contrary to what the left would like you
to believe here's how racial groups
identify politically
non-hispanic white adults
42 identify
as conservative 34 identify as moderate
23 identify as liberal
among non-hispanic black adults
identify as conservative 26 identify as
liberal
51 identify as moderate among blacks
among black americans
okay so in other words there are more
liberals than conservatives among blacks
about six percent
but
virtually all black people like 51 of
them identify as moderate hispanics it's
way worse for the democratic party here
among hispanics 31 of hispanics identify
as conservative 28 identify as liberal
more hispanics now identify as
conservative than liberal and 38
identify as moderates
so as the democratic party gets more and
more liberal
they are leaving behind the entire
american population
and yet joe biden is held hostage by his
own base because 50 of his party is
progressive
and most of his activist base
so what the hell is he going to do
right he's left the entire center of
american politics wide open this is
what's so astonishing about joe biden's
presidency all he had to do was have a
little bit of guts nate silver the poll
analyst
he made a really good point but people
tend to think of joe biden as moderate
joe biden joe biden is not a moderate
says nate's over joe biden is a person
who is wherever the center of the
democratic party is so if the center of
the democratic party moves to the left
so does joe biden so joe biden's a
bellwether he's not a leader he's a
bellwether so if joe biden moved into
bernie sanders territory it's because
his base is in bernie sanders territory
the problem is the country ain't in
bernie sanders territory so the more
democrats reflect this the more
democrats move to the left and by the
way
studies demonstrate the republican their
republican platform has basically been
stagnant since 2010
democratic platform has moved wildly to
the left
as they've done this joe biden has moved
along with them
so it's not that joe biden is just a
fool who moved to the left
although i think he is a fool for not
standing up it's that this is who joe
biden always was he was the cork bobbing
on the eddies of democratic party
politics and wherever the democratic
party was that is where he was
well democratic party politics is now
completely disconnected from the
american population the only reason joe
biden was elected is because he was not
donald trump that was not a green light
to all of the idiotic democratic
strategies it was not a green light to
all of their garbage policies
and it is hilarious that the democrats
keep trying to ram down policies the
american people hate and then they look
around think
why why doesn't anybody follow us the
answer is because your party is not
reflective of the american population
by the way roy teshera right remember
he's the guy who suggested a new
emerging democratic majority he said
that as more minorities
were were present in the demographics of
american life there would be a radical
shift over to the left in american
politics
he came out with an article just a few
weeks ago saying that the hispanic vote
was moving conservative and this broke
his model he came out yesterday he said
uh guys the asian vote is moving
conservative it's breaking my model
because it's not that they're moving
conservative it's that everyone is now
ronald reagan circa 1964.
everybody else stayed the same the
democratic party just moved wildly to
the left and when the democratic party
of today is too far left for the
democratic party of 2010 that shows you
how far left they've moved because the
democratic party of 2010 was not a
moderate party
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content